for thousands of migrants the journey to
Western Europe continues full of strain
and uncertainty many came here to
Croatia hoping to continue North by a
Slovenia or Hungary both countries have
since tightened their borders and all of
money we are from kobani and we're
immigrating to Germany with our little
children they destroyed our country they
destroyed our home they destroyed
everything I'm taking my children to
Germany because life at home is over
overnight migrants protested on a
highway linking northern Croatia with
slovenia their message is clear they
went out of Croatia to go onward
jubilation elsewhere at Croatia's border
with Hungary they've made it across and
cries of appreciation to Hungarian
officials sending refugees on to Austria
hundreds are being ushered two trains
that will take them on to austria's
border but for most eastern europe's
conflicting and shifting migration
policies mean many forced stops whether
in croatia slovenia or hungary
conditions are often makeshift at best
but many keep their eyes on their goal
Jimmy what he needs studying at
University
leave the world three we don't you don't
go to Germany or Sweden to to take just
money and saving we need those studying
me toward need to build our future the
journey is drawing to a close for many
of the thousands who have made it to
Germany's southern border like here in
fri lösung but what happens next is a
question of politics as Germany hammers
out a new asylum policy and pushes for
an EU redistribution scheme